ah le fameux pops écoles que de
souvenirs d'enfance mais aujourd'hui ces
sucettes glacées sont devenus bien plus
élégante et les fruits sont à l'honneur
voici les pétasses l epal et assèche
veut dire c'est ma culture mexicaine
d'origine vers la silva est
littéralement tombé dedans lorsqu'il
était petit
c'est quoi les palettes as un fait les
pas la tasse de sorts des desserts
glacés
c'est un dessert complet partager en
famille un tamis en tout le temps
sortent aussi fait chaud le mexique avec
la chaleur et si plage peut dire
revendiqué la paternité du fameux par
étapes avec les souvenirs ça remontait
jusqu'à magna et sortu l epal et assez
il vient blâma à chercher les côtés de
sauver les fruits on préfère le mix des
fruits des deux fruits
alors on paie sa missive rahman al et
cherchant des signes reviendra mac un
peu s'est marié dans la cuisine
aujourd'hui départ et à ce sont presque
devenus des oeuvres d'art ils sont une
invitation à l'exotisme
on en retrouve de plus en plus ici dans
les bars laitiers les marchés et les
festivals ils ont souvent des
combinaisons inattendues match à noix de
coco qui oui moi je me rappelle ma
nounou phases au sol lorsque l'état
jeune jean gonthier connaît bien des
sucettes glacées
il donne des formations aux
propriétaires de crémerie pour fabriquer
ces pop mexicaine
c'est christiane toute la palette on l'a
fait donc ici nous avons le budget de
mojito framboise mangue citron
pina colada fraises et rhubarbe pistache
à nana peu importe le fric que vous
utilisez il faut avoir un taux de fruit
d'un 0 70 point c'est faire des pas
l'état ce citron ou encore aux
framboises
pas si difficile c'est un petit truc un
peu d'eau l'eau vient juste comme
assurer un peu que notre palette album
est vraiment blessé parce que c'est
l'eau qui gèle donc l'eau qui est à
l'intérieur du fruit va vraiment nous
aider à faire un bon là par hasard
enfin votre préféré la wii en fait vous
préférez ont fait la manche mangue sucre
au et jus de citron pour équilibrer le
ph
on garde la moitié du fluide pour les
mettre à l'intérieur de nos moins plus
que le fruit vol dans un milieu acide de
ce qu'ils vont ressortir le goût du
fruit et vous voyez quand même temps
qu'on a beaucoup moins d'eau et ce à
cause que la mangue hausse à bordeaux en
commun a dit oui ce serait son patron un
méthanier lui parce qu'il faut avoir
assez le death parle pour que le jus
puce prendre sa place si grand talent et
la ronde ainsi que ça j'ai bien hâte et
une place au congélateur comme ça ce
type de congélateurs industriel permet
de congeler les palets tasse en 12
minutes
howard
est-ce impressionnant là ça sent la
framboise et l'âme angle l'envolée du
beau morceau demande si la recette peut
varier selon la teneur en sucre des
fruits choisi c'est le cas avec le
citron avec le citron les puces autour
de 20 le portant de fruits parce que
nous la mecque le fruit y ait un peu
trop et c'est d'abord aller au même
niveau que les autres
[Musique]
ok souvenirs d'enfance mais bonnart
d'adultes bruit absolument pire là elle
nous a préparé trois pelles et tu as à
saveur mexicaine
effectivement mais l'état marais c'est
un fruit et couleurs blanc j'adore ça
j'avais souvent goûté avec du soleil de
marée mais comme ça ça fait quelque
chose de frais avec le côté acidulé la
why are ses entrées blanches et roses et
les fameuses hibiscus qui est couleurs
franches à 16 heures
mais l'hibiscus c'est une fleur vous
avez un fruit là dedans ou c'est juste
seule une effusion allez messieurs ce
que vous faites dans un fleuve qui est
séché mais qui garde ses propriétés
alors une fois qu'ils ont là fait
bouillir avec bello ça toutes ses
propriétés de la flore ils sortent à
nous on pourrait ajouter ensuite ça
dépasse il a fui y est sucré eau passe
trop souple est bon d'ajouter un peu
plus dessus un peu des sites en recul et
versez dans le moule de reste encore
très très fort la future galets mangin
palace en soirée à dimanche c'est
vraiment une icône de notre culture